the girag an experience and they're all
nice I'm not worried about I'm not
afraid of it like cuz I like the people
so much who I've met involved I've never
met anybody involved in who I didn't
like yeah they're nice people right all
of them are nice people none of them are
dicks none of them give that energy off
like they all know they could strangle
me like there's nobody nobody makes you
feel that way well that's why I guy like
Matt Serra is such a good guy because
he's got such a good character you know
and then you kind of notice that from a
lot of fighters right
they have great character and one of the
reason why they have great character is
they're they don't have a problem with
their ego they're controlled they
understand who they are they feel good
yeah never uncomfortable around any of
them yeah like never for that reason at
least no matter who they are or what
position they're in they they're all
kind of the same none of them none of
them come off like with that alpha
energy that other athletes give you I
remember on ona you know if everybody
choked you I used to do that yeah BJ was
the first guy he was coming off a loss
and I wanted to see what it felt like
like I knew wouldn't be the same but I
had seen arm bars and I wanted to know
how what does it feel like when somebody
grabs your arm that way so he did they
were all pretty gentle phaidor put me in
a [ __ ] good one
yeah yeah yeah his hurt but I to feel
those things you like it gives you such
a respect for the fact that there's guys
that are doing this for real oh yeah
this is a guy just showing some [ __ ]
idiot on the radio didn't John Jones
like gently leg kick you to know John
Jones [ __ ] put a hard leg kick
because it was like he was like wait cut
wheat week so he might not have been the
best of [ __ ] moods but he put me in
kicked me across the leg it hurts so bad
no but I'm being honest I think he did
it like I'm sure hit let me say let me
hear this look at my [ __ ] like hands
up put your dukes up that's light it
what compared to what he could have done
that's light but I almost threw up
look at him look at you I almost vomited
I had to go to the bathroom so I thought
it's not faint okay but I'm telling you
right now that wasn't even 50% oh no not
even close that was probably wasn't even
30% all that was was like the weight of
his leg ya know he could have really
[ __ ] leveled mom I
just chose me I've had a few guys do
things who hurt you the most
John thank you I'd like price I'm not
exactly how long it was it might need
been [ __ ] up so I put one on for three
months after that but no face that you'd
get ready good - yeah this is always
fader got you in an arm lock
Oh who's got you in a heel hook cause
Brock Brock Lesnar no you let Brock
Lesnar touch your knees yeah that's so
terrible yeah yeah they'd all be shot
punched you yeah
there's a whole series of people beatin
on you but it was never it was never
like it was never like hey let's see how
the hurt Oh John wants you to punch you
a different time Oh uriah punching are
you this little video series of you
getting beat up by UFC fighters this is
so horrible rocks were oh yeah yeah yeah
was that Frank or Ken ah Frank oh
Anderson kicked you yeah not hard though
pianist is a nice guy he wouldn't kick
me that hard that's good for him man
I'm glad you you we're gonna have to
kick you in the arm yes
oh you break your arm easy yeah I didn't
want but I always trust these guys like
I know that none of them are gonna do it
so hard that they do anything to me
that's gonna damage because they all
know I'm not fighting right but I all
know that they could that I just trust
them for some reason I trust them to be
gentle I don't know why well there
aren't they're nice people
plus they know it's the radio yeah I'm
not trying to hurt you John got you in a
choke - yeah this is so crazy
yeah all these people [ __ ] you look
fatal if I wouldn't let go he was going
to go now he enjoyed it oh do you know
fate or just I got you again yeah he tap
tap to you like three times
Rashaad getting you in a triangle oh my
god that is hilarious yeah yeah Rhonda
arm Barbie I had some really fun ones
but I wish I had done more of these
because it was really a bit done out of
respect for what they do right just to
feel what it's like to watch someone
who's world-class and one of the best
alive at doing that and it almost sudden
to have them do it to you felt like [ __ ]
man this is how good this guy is at this
how did she get the gig with the UFC
how'd that work Dana had asked me
on time you know we known each other a
long time and he he'd say one day we're
gonna work together we're gonna do
something I don't know what and I was
like all right you know and I would see
him in events and whatever and I just
got a phone call one day he's like hey
man we're doing a podcast with Matt's
already one do it he [ __ ] just called
me and goes here's the money do you want
to do the podcast
it was a phone call from Dana freeing me
the podcast he didn't NAT was already in
place and I said yeah I would love to so
he worked out a couple of things with my
job where I was able to do something
else with my name on it and he just
hired me Wow
I'm not hired like you know I hired as a
comedian who loves UFC like Matt guy who
can of course lay by play call it
analyze jujitsu so beautifully and you
know that's not what I do ya know it's
it's interesting that the UFC even has a
podcast you know
yeah UFC unfiltered yeah I mean it was I
it was they could have just got to
analysts to do it but I think Dana just
wanted a different tone to it
[Applause]